you
[Music]
start service acres angel Jordan a leak
area chair at D create associate
professor at CMU ec department he is
part of the Scilab and connect Center
he works in networks and security and
stalking but Universal monitoring and
universal sketching all right thank you
thanks for having me
this summer school seems like some fun
projects are going on
so there's actually based of a talk I
gave recently at ACM stock which is
surprising that they invited a systems
person to a theory conference so this is
actually an interesting story of
serendipitous collaboration between
theory and systems it originally started
off doing it in the context of network
monitoring but thinking more broadly I
actually think that this type of work
has broader applications to telemetry
and analytics and whatever kind of
monitoring we want to do in future IOT
systems before I didn't actually want to
thank a lot of people who actually did
most of this work I'm just here as an
evangelist for this work the original
universal monitoring team Alan Lea was a
student at Georgia Tech sorry Johns
Hopkins has advised there's a man who's
sort of behind most of this set of
theoretical breakthroughs in universal
sketching we've also done a lot of
implementations to show that it's not
just theory but there's also a lot of
practical implementations on different
kinds of platforms so there's a bunch of
folks who've helped us do these things
all right so so let's sort of dive in to
the motivation for this work so the
motivation for this work really stems
from the fact that if you are managing a
large network system an IOT system for
example you actually have a whole
different slew of analytics tasks that
you actually want to run on top of the
system so for example I may want to
estimate what kind of traffic is going
through the network I might want to
estimate different properties of the
data through my through my network I
might want to do different kinds of
uncheck for different kinds of anomalies
has there been a spike in a particular
region are there new kinds of heavy
hitters who are sending a lot of traffic
and and so on and so forth
so so these are the kinds of analytics
tasks that I might be interested in a
network setting now she's a very
informal problem definition of what I
would like to do so imagine an IOT
deployment or network deployment I have
a bunch of different telemetry or
monitoring applications and then notice
that the the very fact that I'm doing
monitoring means that many of these
tasks might be unforeseen I may not know
until the deployment happens or until
the system is actually running or what
I'm looking for
obviously this problem is trivial if
there are no resource constraints that
the T factors in a network or in an IOT
deployment there are key resource
constraints on your elements that are
monitoring the state of your system so
these could be either CPU or memory
constraints or bandwidth constrained in
reporting the statistics to a central
agent or in an IOT setting things like
energy either become becomes very very
bottomless well okay so so are sort of
generic problem is really deciding what
kind of monitoring primitives do I want
to run on my sensors on my monitors on
my network routers and so on such that
they respect these kinds of resource
constraints they operate within the
system parameters but still provide high
fidelity estimates I provide high
accuracy for the kinds of applications I
care about that if I actually wanted to
detect an attack or detect if there is a
spike in energy usage in a particular
environment and so on I do want to
provide high accuracy for those
applications all right so so this is the
driving question for this work is what
monitoring parameters do I want it on
now again I'm going to use networking as
a driving application or a driving
scenario but you can think this has more
broader applications as well okay so
sort of the traditional approach you
would think about doing this is as a
sort of data comes to you in a streaming
model the very simplest thing you can do
is just run some sort of a uniform
sampling algorithm and then sort of
collect the data and then send it to
some central agent for running estimates
on top of that okay so so for example in
the context of network monitoring the
most common
used primitive today is something called
net flow or sea flow or other kinds of
sort of industry turns so what it does
is sort of it samples the incoming
packets and random groups packets with
the similar pattern into what are called
flows and then reports these sort of
flow flows and their counters to some
central collection point okay so here's
a quick animation you have like sort of
different flows your flows one three and
six flow one has like five packets flow
three as one packet flow six is one
packet and so on as these sort of items
come through and through the system this
monitor is sampling them discarding some
of these samples updating counters for a
subset of these and then it reports
whatever it sort of sampled the sample
flow reports to some central agent and
then I can estimate different properties
of the stream that I wanted to monitor
using the sampled reports have collected
okay so this is a very typical workflow
that happens in most monitoring tasks
today now the problem is and many people
have observed it is sampling is a
reasonable starting point but it is
actually not great for a number of
fine-grained tasks for example if I want
to do anomaly detection or some kind of
security monitoring or finding the
heavy-hitter
that's in the network sampling may
actually not give you the right answer
now an alternative approach and there's
been a lot of really cool theoretical
work in this space is what are called
sketching or streaming algorithms so in
a general workflow here is think about
it is like if you tell me what metric
you are interested in like saying I want
to find the maximum value of a data
stream or I want to find the median
value of a data stream or I want to find
the percentiles of these values and a
data stream and so on if you tell me the
metric a priori there are a number of
very cool compact highly efficient
algorithms or sketching algorithms that
can maintain a compressed data structure
that are extremely optimized for
monitoring that particular metric so if
I say I want to find heavy hitters I
want to find the entropy of the stream I
want to detect people talking to a
number of different destinations and so
on and so forth I can actually go and
develop these custom algorithms deploy
them on my monitor
nodes collect the data structures
relevant for that particular monitoring
tasks and then report them back so and
there's been a lot of fascinating sort
of theory in this sort of in this
literature let's solve these kind of
problems
now of course from a practical systems
point of view imagine you're developing
an IOT sensor or an IOT monitoring
system this is not a tenable or a
practical trajectory the set of metrics
I am carrying I care about in a stream
is always constantly growing and I also
don't know a priori what matrix I want
to monitor the state of my network so
clearly from a systems point of view
this is not a great idea because it
entails higher complexity on your sensor
which is a limited compute and bandwidth
it's obviously higher development time
like every one of us has to go develop
new algorithms as new applications
emerge and and moreover even if you
think about sort of a reprogrammable or
a reef flashable sensor that you can
actually change the algorithm that's
learning on it even that is not
sufficient because at any given point of
time the resources on that node have
been tightly committed to the metric of
interest already if I want to do some
the retroactive analysis and ask hey
what was the value of this metric m1
five minutes ago
unless that metric was already being
monitored I actually don't know that
value so it's not very good for time
series analysis or attractive forensics
and so on and so forth so so this is
kind of like this sort of dilemma these
sort of two classes of metrics two
classes of estimation approaches generic
approach is like sampling which are sort
of okay but not very accurate or custom
algorithms that are highly accurate but
entail a lot of complexity okay and sort
of from a systems point of view this
question had sort of been has been
bugging people for a long time
interestingly the same problem has also
been bugging the theory community so the
theory community is asking a similar
question and they sort of open question
from a set of theory workshop on this
question of is there a vision for a
universal sketching solution that is
rather than commit your sketch to a
single function is it possible to define
these kind of sketching primitives that
are generic
across a wide range of possible
functions okay so so this was an open
question sort of back in 2011 and people
didn't really know there is an answer to
this question and no and so on so so
based on the sort of the ideal vision
that we want for developing a robust
monitoring infrastructure for future IOT
deployments a few technical deployments
is what I would call the sort of vision
for Universal monitoring and the idea
here is as your stream of data goes
through your monitoring node I I can do
some amount of data processing in a
streaming fashion I want to keep as
generic a computation or a data
structure as possible on what I call the
monitoring data claim the hardware the
IOT sensors I report this sort of
generic or compressed data structure
back to some sort of central collection
agents so something in the management or
control claim and the idea in the hope
is that whatever I am collecting can be
used for a variety of downstream
applications or tasks somebody else can
go write queries to on top of this sort
of compressed data structure and say oh
I want to reactivate or recover
properties of the stream that my
application really cares about ok so
again sort of this is this one data
structure for a wide variety of tasks
and the nice thing is actually sort of
naturally what I would call laid binding
and this is a nice property to have from
a system systems perspective is that
when I deploy the sensor build this
Hardware invest my developers time in
deploying these algorithms I do not need
to know a priori what my customers want
so this is actually a very powerful
practical architecture I do not need to
know what the customer wants it before
deploying them out there in the real
world
ok so this is kind of like a crazy
visions like I mean it's not clear how I
can do it so obviously a bunch of
different technical challenges in this
problem space that we actually don't
know the answers to at this time
ok so a bunch of open questions first of
all the sort of this theoretical
question of does a universal sketch
actually exist like this an open
question is the sketch actually exists
even if it does it may be impractical to
implement right so what's the point of
having a theoretically elegant algorithm
if it's not very practical to implement
on a resource Kahn
strained hardware or a router and so on
yeah so so the definition of you know
surskit is exactly this right you give
me a set of functions or a set of
metrics or applications you want to run
I have to put like one single counting
data structure on my monitor such that
all of those applications will have high
accuracy correct exactly yeah so the set
of applications might be unknown or
unforeseen but you might be may bind you
may bound them and say they may come
from this family of functions and so on
will be sort of will qualify what that
universality means in a second but think
about the way there are any number of
tasks that a future network operator or
a future IOT analytics framework may
think about and the counters and keeping
should be sufficient to estimate that
particular application sorry so again
the idea there is a resource constraint
so I don't have infinite memory I don't
have infinite self processing so it has
to be a compact data structure so sorry
so typically this the sketching and the
streaming algorithms sublinear in terms
of the number of items in the stream and
I sort of define a straining problem a
little bit better right yeah obviously
if I had like infinite things I would
they dumped on the data I send all the
data but that means that I'm violating
the CPU consumption that's a memory
consumption and the communication cost
that's not a viable option for IOT or
routers or anything in practice okay so
so the question first question is does a
universal sketch exist and before I go
there I should sort of give a little bit
of background to formally define what I
mean by a sketching or a streaming
algorithm and again I'm going to sort of
use some of the standard terminology
from the theory community to explain
what these problems are okay so here's a
very quick one slide overview of what a
stream or a sketching algorithm means so
so you have a data stream so a stream is
of length M say the number of packets or
the number of sensor readings that you
are getting and there are n unique items
like say unique IP addresses or unique
sort of values of energy readings and so
on so I want to use sort of a
small amount of memory in terms of the
size of this tree I don't I cannot I
cannot use like sort of I want to use
like something like sub linear in M or N
and sketches are like sin essentially a
class of these data stream summaries
that intuitively do some kind of like
hash based computation or like some
compressed data structure of the stream
so so one way to think about it say for
example so at least for me intuitively
is so the sort of zeroth order problem
is sort of checking whether you you saw
this item before so this bloom filter
you can think of as a sketch it's a very
sort of very simple sketch that lets you
do set membership queries without
actually having to store every item
you've seen so far so and think about
sketches or data streams streaming
algorithms I sort of extensions to sort
of a bloom filter like approach a data
structure that also lets you do like
sort of volumetric or counting queries
not just membership queries
again it's very loose hand wavy we are
thinking about a sketch if you've never
seen a sketch before think of it is like
some some sort of a bloom bloom filter
plus counting capabilities okay and
they're actually sort of a lot of
seminal sort of theory results that talk
about the feasibility of doing these
kind of computations for different kinds
of metrics of interests on your stream
right so there's the sort of one of the
earliest papers was in 85 the a-maz
paper in 96 actually won the godel prize
all right so typically in the standard
sketching formulation the way the theory
has progressed is you define a
particular metric say for example I want
to find the number of unique items in a
stream I want to find the first order
moment I want to find the second moment
of a stream and so on so so given a
particular metric there's a particular
sketch that is probably optimal in terms
of the memory accuracy trade-offs for
that particular metric of interest so if
you like one algorithm that solves one
problem and that is the classical way of
thinking about sketching or streaming
algorithms now universality or Universal
question Universal straining I'm asking
here and again going back to sort of
your question about what do I mean by
universality this is a little bit of a
restricted version of universality which
is that if you think about the frequency
vector
which is the frequency of item I all
existing many of the existing sketches
that they think about is you can write
them as either like summation of FI
squared summation F X cubed summation F
fry on fi log fi and so on and so forth
there are some functions of the
frequency vector now we are asking
universality is really about can I
estimate an arbitrary G summation of the
G of FI some G function that I don't
know but I am restricted to this class
of functions where G comes in this form
that my function is of this form
expressed as a summation of the
frequency vectors so this is the classic
this is a theoretical formulation of it
so so one of the things we've found is
many things that we actually want and
practice actually map with that so I
have to think about whether the
particular function you're thinking
about can be mapped into this particular
things actually I'll tell you the
theoretical result so then you can see
whether it actually fits that particular
form or not right or maybe there's an
approximate version of the function
you're writing actually might be mapping
to that but that's actually a very good
open question which I don't know is like
if you have an application in mind does
it fit my model that I I don't know I
can't just give you a negative answer is
like hey this is there or not all right
so so here's an example so in sort of
you can write this sort of any many of
the classical sketches like first order
unique elements enter P sketches and all
of them can be written in this form as
some kind of G of some G some function
alright so and this is where the sort of
this this somewhat counterintuitive
result in theory that actually says that
indeed there exists a universal approach
or a universal data structure or a
universal sketch that can support a very
large family of functions so so these
are sort of this class of functions that
intuitively don't go grow faster than fi
squared so if the function does not grow
faster monotonically faster than fi
squared it turns out there is a
universal sketch construction for that
particular class of form
okay and the theory is sort of that's an
excerpt of a universality proof and then
the existence she'll prove is like where
there is a universal sketch that exists
that actually can be used to estimate
this G sum with high probability using
sort of poly log rhythmic memory again
sub linear memory in terms of the stream
sites okay now again I did not come up
with this theory this is like really
cool theory and probably beyond my
comprehension but it's actually a very
counterintuitive mini and sort of
interesting result that shows the
feasibility of developing a universal
construction for a large family of
functions and again as I said many
things we cared about on the network
setting seemed to fit this sort of
definition very naturally as a sketch so
actually you'll see sort of some of the
results I think one of the nice things
of universality is actually this laid
binding and I don't need to know a
priori that what is necessary right and
also the nice thing also we'll see is
actually that it's better to give more
memory the union of the memory to like a
universal sketch then fragment you're
sort of resources across multiple
sketches so so one of the sort of the
from both the systems and a theoretical
perspective is actually interesting
actually say that we'll see as the
portfolio grows it's better to give the
resources to our Universal sketch and
fragmented across custom sketches for
each different application and again set
up this G can be more than just like fi
fi squared right it can actually be a
little bit more broader than that now so
here's the intuitive way I thought up
self I've requested a theory people do
explain this to me a little bit more
intuitively and intuitively the way to
think about it is like goes back to sort
of classical heavy hitters and heavy
hitters are items in the stream that
appear a lot of times like say the one
person was getting ddosed or the one
person that's sending a lot of traffic
or heavy hitters in your stream now
intuitively you can essentially split
sort of it the stream into two cases
either there is indeed one very large G
heavy hitter not a heavy hitter in the
classical sense but a heavy hitter that
contributes to the G sum in which case
you can use a classical heavy hitter
algorithm and you are done you basically
get a very accurate estimate of the G
sum if you just find the
he does the any too heavy l to hear the
L to normal stream now the second case
is more interesting is actually suppose
the stream is such that there is no such
sufficiently large heavy heater that's
contributing a significant amount of
mass then there is a strick where you
can actually think about running sort of
sort of a recursive version of this on
progressively smaller sampled sub
streams and in fact it's a sort of a
logarithmic number of sub streams and it
turns out you can actually prove that
finding heavy eaters on the sub sort of
recursively sample streams is sufficient
to estimate the G so okay
so again this is sort of a very hand
wavy explanation of why universal
sketching actually works so let me
actually sort of show you sort of what
the counting this data structure
actually looks like so what we're going
to do is given a stream and we are going
to use a number of sort of a logarithmic
number of zero one hash functions
essentially say whether or not this
particular item in the stream is being
sampled so I will have like level 0
level 1 dot a dot on the level login and
at every level I am going to run a
classical heavy-hitter sketch so this
can be account men count sketch any
number of algorithms that you can sort
of plug in and play here so any number
of classical heavy-hitter algorithms can
be plugged in to this framework that
does L to heavy hitters then I get the
heavy hitters and their respective
counters from every level and it turns
out that is sufficient to get a very
accurate estimate of a G sum through a
recursive computation now so this is
actually what the intuitively the data
structure looks like and if you think
think about our original vision of
universal monitoring really what we're
going to do is put this sampling and
sketch counting heavy-hitter sketches in
our data plane so there's a bunch of
hash function computations and these
sketches sketching counters and I'm
going to push all the
application-specific computation say oh
I want to do DDoS as DDoS detection I
wanted to find the top K people in the
stream I want to estimate the entropy of
a particular dimension and so on I'm
going to push all of those into what I
would call the logical control plane
some sort of analytics agent or a cloud
back-end or what
so so all these sort of in some sense
are offline
right I mean think about all the
application-specific competition they
may still be real-time but they're not
running on the IOT sensor itself they're
running in some back-end agent yeah oh
great question so so so we'll get to
that in a little bit of in a little bit
so it's so so there's actually some so
you can think about it that way as well
so but there's actually one of the
things where you where the theory meets
the practice has to be a little bit more
careful and we like give me examples
where in some cases memory is the
bottleneck and in the case that's the
right thing to do in some cases where
you become like processing or CPU
becomes a bottleneck you have to come up
with alternatives or like approximation
so that particular log and cache
computation itself so and in fact we
have found that in some cases I'll tell
you about that all right so this comes
back to sort of your sort of prefetching
the second question is like okay I've
told you the universal sketch
construction at a high level is it
actually practical to implement I don't
yet have sort of experience implementing
on sort of low powered IOT platforms yet
and that's kind of where I would like to
see this implemented but I can talk
about a couple of different experiences
that we've had in implementing on more
sort of classical network centric
platforms so if we implement it in like
sort of an emerging programmable
software router or switch architecture
called p4 we've done it on other network
processor platforms and also looked at
sort of virtual switching platforms that
are very common in like data centers
like for example everything in Azure is
running on top of a virtual switch you
can imagine running telemetry or
monitoring applications inside the
virtual switch inside your data centers
and so on so and cool thing for us is
like most of these sort of systems are
already open source and our
implementation too is as well ok so so
and this sort of highlights again these
sort of interesting mapping of the
theoretical construction to practice and
where we have to be a little bit careful
about how we do the implementation so so
here's our sort of mapping to sort of p4
and sort of one sort of the classical
wave
my way of doing it is to say the entire
data plane goes to p4 and the only
application estimation goes to the
control plane but it turns out this
actually was not the right thing to do
for p4 especially because the sketching
layer requires you to do like some sort
of a priority queue or a sorting
operation inside the data plane and that
turns out to be beyond the capabilities
of what this p4 Hardware can actually do
so so then it sort so what we did was
essentially said we made a pragmatic
choice to say well we can't do a
priority queue or a sorting operation in
the data plane instead we'll just like
sacrifice a little bit more
communication overhead send the raw
reports the raw data structure to the
control plane and say you do the sorting
power icon to the sorting part okay so
we have to be careful about how we map
this computation and this was an
interesting sort of exercise that showed
the the naive way of mapping it to the
hardware may not be the optimal way so
we sort of pushed the sorting part of
the control plane as well but again this
is the conscious trade-off we incur a
little bit more of a communication
overhead a few megabytes more for a very
large string but it's actually feasible
to map in the hardware now similarly so
this is make sort of experience with
this sort of pre programmable switch
architecture the other thing actually I
want to point out is actually we've also
implemented it in software switching or
software router platforms and here this
is where some of the questions you asked
about is like is the service is it
possible to compute these sort of login
hashes and so on comes into play so it
turns out in these sort of software
router or software switching platforms
memory is not a problem you actually
have a lot of memory on your server
the problem is really that the number of
times you touch this back at a number of
computations or number of cycles per
packet is what kills you and so that's
where you actually realize that hey look
we we will not be able to handle line
rate computation using these classical
sketch implementations using on this
commodity software switches on commodity
servers so even the classical sort of
the system's tricks like or use DP DK
use kernel bypass all of those things
are not sufficient to solve this problem
you have to do something a little bit
more rigorous there are ways to solve
this problem if you can you can sort of
do heuristics and so on but are not
Solutions so our idea was actually said
that we sort of reformulated the
sketching problem for software and said
if we can change the theory problem
slightly and say hey look I'm willing to
sacrifice a little bit more memory but I
want to reduce the CPU or I'm actually
willing to tolerate some delay in the in
the answer and I can wait for some
convergence before I get an accurate
estimate so you can sort of trade-off
delays and trade-off more memory to
actually reduce the CPU dramatically and
these sort of tricks we actually can get
really really high rate like say 40 sort
of close to 40 gig on a single core or
on a software switching platform with
some sort of additional huge successful
okay so the point of this is to say that
hey look even assets caching is a great
idea but if you give me a particular
platform I need to some sense spend some
systems engineering and careful even
clearly tweaking to actually make it
practical for a particular platform so
if I think about an IOT platform that
has energy constraints or communication
constraints I may need to tweak this
further so I need to think about in an
IOT platform for example I imagine most
of the energy actually goes in the radio
layer communication is a lot the court
sort of kills the battery on most of
these devices thing and so we actually
have to be a little bit more cognizant
maybe CPU and memory is not the problem
but communication cost is the problem
and we may need to compress the data
structure further before we send it to
the controller and so on
I'm not done that on this that is
speculative all right so so so far I've
told you hey there is a universal sketch
and at least this preliminary evidence
on a couple of different platforms
suggests there is a feasible roadmap to
implementing them and sort of realizing
the theoretical benefits that it
promises now obviously one question is
hey why not just do custom sketches for
a bunch of different metrics is it not
comp is it actually competitive versus
running a custom sketch for every single
application so we get a number of sort
of praise driven evaluations to actually
understand is a universal sketch
competitive with respect to a custom
sketch for say f1 f2 f3 and and so on
and so forth ok now the first sort of
result here the y-axis is sort of the
error rate and the x-axis is different
tasks heavy-hitters DDoS
action change detection entropy
estimation and so on so they give the
same amount of memory to a custom sketch
as well as the same amount of memory to
a universal sketch and we check how much
how much off in terms of the error of
this particular task you are of course
we have ground truth where we can do
exact computation and we compare with
expert to the ground truth and the error
gap I mean
so obviously the custom sketch is going
to do better right because I'm late
doing one thing it is doing this one
thing well but the gap is not like
obscenely high the gap was around like
less than sort of for person which is
something tolerable given this amount of
memory right so notice that if you
actually give what I'm doing here is
slightly unfair to universal sketching
because if I build a system with four
tasks I would need to do 600 plus 600
plus section after section at 2.4 MB for
the custom algorithm but universal
sketch only get 6 and at KB overall so
it's a little bit of an unfair
comparison to universal sketch in this
case now here's the more interesting
result is what happens when I don't have
just a single app but I have a portfolio
of different estimation applications I
care about and this is where thought of
things get interesting where you say if
I compare against the portfolio of
applications we tried different
portfolios app set 1 2 & 3 on the x-axis
and you actually realize you see that as
the application portfolio grows there is
a clear win for universal sketch in fact
the accuracy of a universal sketch
becomes better because it actually
getting sort of more memory across the
portfolio it's better to use the memory
with the universal sketch than
fragmented for individual tasks of
course there are still some tasks on
which custom sketch is doing better but
overall the trend is like is in favor of
universal sketch approach okay so that's
sort of where we are in terms of
universal sketches now there's a whole
bunch of open questions and I don't know
the answers to especially if you think
about an IOT environment or a
system-wide environment where there are
multiple sensors multiple dimensions
hierarchical dimensions of interest and
so on so I'll sort of briefly define
those problems and say I don't actually
know what the answers to these problems
so in a sort of more general
system-wide setting you can think of the
the data are getting actually
is a high-dimensional data flowing
through your network there's typically
for one dimension yeah so think about
like uni-dimensional
data that's flowing through a system so
now you can think about a high
dimensional data stream where say even
in the in the network case you have like
I I P address destination address source
address destination address source port
destination port protocol and so on it's
like why I mentioned already and you can
think about in sort of a sensor
deployment where you are collecting many
more dimensions of interest okay so in
the more general case you actually have
a number of these sensing locations you
have many nodes and many dimensions of
interest now the question then becomes
how do I actually map this
multi-dimensional problem and sort of
unspecial things sort of spatio-temporal
problem to this to the setting okay now
a trivial solution solution might be to
like place every sketch for every single
dimension on every single node but
that's obviously not the most optimal
thing you can do we can do a little bit
better so we actually showed where we
can do a little bit better in terms of
placement and coordination across these
sketches at least for sort of one but
the case of the number of dimensions is
small a more open question is when you
get to the multi dimensional question
you may also be interest you may be able
to exploit some kind of hierarchical
structure in the data to actually do
better and we are not doing any of that
stuff right now in the multi dimensional
problem and sort of the holy grail here
is to think about having like one global
monitor that all the data goes through
and can I get the equivalent accuracy of
having all the data streaming through
one global node even though I have a
system-wide deployment I don't quite
know how to do that yet okay that sort
of the Holy Grail a holy grail of this
sort of system-wide placement and
analytics problem all right so that's
kind of where we are in terms of
universal sketching actually think that
is a very cool primitive that can have
very broad applications not just in
networking but also in the IOT domain
especially going forward where there's
going to be many diverse tasks and many
different kinds of estimates you
actually want to do and this could
actually be a sort of a bit
building block of how you build future
analytics at elementary capabilities for
IOT and so on so and the rest of this
talk I'd sort of briefly touched upon a
couple of other areas that are relevant
to sort of this workshop agenda one is
talking about sort of interesting
machine learning problems at the
intersection of sort of machine learning
and IOT security and privacy to talk
about some of these problems and also
talk a little bit about the sort of new
large initiative we are launching at CMU
called conics which is talking about
sort of sort of a broader umbrella for
many of these different open problems in
general ok so again sort of a set of
sort of interesting again not meant to
be comprehensive but just to sort of
pique your interest about interesting
problems or applications of machine
learning to security in privacy in this
particular space so so one problem I'm
interested in is looking at sort of can
we model the behavior of an IOT device
and automatically extract a behavioral
model for what a normal behavior of an
IOT device is going to be like so the
examples of the motivation here is many
of the high profile hacks and many of
the high profile incidents we see today
are somebody went and broke into your
IOT device right there's a camera there
somebody happened at the camera I know
maybe sort of my stream is going out
somewhere else right so now one question
is well these IOT devices are not
general-purpose computer so somebody
using them as general-purpose computer
is a behavioral aberration from the
normal expected behavior of a thermostat
or a camera and and so on so the
question then becomes can we build
robust behavioral models that capture
the footprint of an IOT device and use
it to sort of flag for security
violations and so on now the challenge
of course is how do I do it in the
presence of noisy and unlabeled data
right so so so this is this kind of
between machine learning and security in
general so machine learning typically
assumes that if somebody's nicely give
you a label data set at least many
classical formulations of it though and
security we actually don't have these
labels and often it's due a serial
setting where you also need to worry
about the possibility of an adversary
polluting or active act actively evading
your classifier and so on so we have
some preliminary ideas here and talked
about
of how we can build sort of a robust
representation sort of a finite state
machine representation of different IOT
devices and use that to flag deviations
for many different kinds of devices so
the idea here is how do we actually make
it robust to polluted incoming data and
how do we actually build a compact
behavioral model that's actually hard
for an adversary period in the future
and so on so another sort of interesting
sort of problem domain I've been
thinking about I don't actually have a
pretty slide for it but sort of the
vision here is think about in really
came about sort of reading a bunch of
news articles like this it turns out if
you use like a service like Airbnb or a
hotel what looks like a thermostat is
actually a camera or a listening device
that spying on you right so now the
question then is like okay I'm a user of
these services I want to be able to walk
into a room and say hey look and sort of
map out the kind of sensors and
capabilities that this particular room
has and say hey this camera is actually
listening to me and that that's a
thermostat or that looks like a smoke
alarm but it's actually a camera that is
listening capabilities and so on so the
idea here is I should be able to walk in
the room and say figure out the
capabilities of individual devices
inside that particular room so I
actually know what I'm getting into
if I'm going to an Airbnb I know what
I'm getting into there's a hidden camera
right there so maybe I'll be careful
about what I do there right so this is
an interesting application of machine
learning right you can think about I can
walk in I can monitor different kinds of
features I can monitor the Wi-Fi the
Bluetooth the energy spectrum I can
monitor the free sort of the RF spectrum
I can monitor visual aids emissions and
so on and so forth I have a bunch of
different features and I want to be able
to say hey this these features is that a
camera or is that a thermostat that lays
a thermostat claims to be a thermostat
looks like a thermostat but it's GM
finger per a.m. footprint looks like it
looks like a camera or its Wi-Fi
footprint looks like a camera can I do
it maybe I can and it turns out there's
actually some interesting preliminary
work by some other folks from this paper
that they were looking at and they
actually had this data set so those of
you looking at for interesting IOT smart
home data set is actually seems like a
nice data set so they they collected
traffic emitted by 31 smart home devices
and so
very standard sort of traffic
fingerprinting techniques look at the
average packet size look at the kind of
protocols the kind of clothes these
particular devices is sending and you
start to create a compact fingerprint
and say hey look if you are sending a
lot of outgoing connections you are
probably a camera or if you're sending
periodic heartbeats you are probably
Amazon Alexa and so on and so forth I
mean nothing sort of fancy there good
question I don't know so then maybe have
to look for some other features so so
this is just yeah so the question is
what what features can you monitor and
maybe there's actually manifestations in
the other participant right maybe there
is a iam foot EEM the the
electromagnetic emissions actually
manifest even though it's wild and so on
or you can actually also think about
like actively doing something to see how
they respond to active in its active
requests and queries I don't know this
is no open question for me actually
being trying to implement this using
proto NN which is like a cool new
compact machine learning algorithm that
you guys have developed actually over
one day and Hutch has been helping me
actually get this running
the results are PPT because I haven't my
coding skills are rusty so alright so
that's sort of interesting applications
of machine learning to security and
privacy the last part I actually do want
talk about like sort of this new big
center that we are actually doing
looking at these problems mean a more
general perspective right so I talked
about sort of monitoring for telemetry
interesting applications of IOT to
machine learning and security a machine
learning coyote security and privacy but
more broadly sort of the goal here is
thinking about there is a lot of
interesting new next-generation
applications of IOT drones self-driving
cars and and so on and so forth that are
sort of essentially require new
capabilities inside the network from the
systems that we are developing and so on
ok so the idea here is the vision here
is that so there's a whole bunch of new
applications and unit network
infrastructures that are going to be
fundamentally changing the way we need
to rethink how we have done classic
systems design and sort of machine
learning and so on so the the new
network infrastructure and this is in
this sort of project called conics the
region here is there going to be extreme
scale think about smart cities pervasive
augmented reality applications and so on
that are going to have a lot of
variability heterogeneity cool
spatio-temporal context having our
applications and they're going to
require low latency communication
otherwise our car is going to crash and
then and so on and so forth okay so so
our works are the goal of the center is
basically saying that we can think about
sort of classical paradigms of billions
of edge devices the cloud or the
internet and so on but really none of
them are a good fit for these emerging
class of applications and we need to
sort of bring some more structure to
this chaos and in particular we actually
believe that the network infrastructure
or the sort of the middle of this
networker middle of the middle layer is
going to play a much bigger role than
it's classically played in the system
sorry
so good question so one thing over to
solve all self-driving cars are actually
having sort of massive GPUs and stuff
inside the system so think about like
the okay the version of it like can you
put a set can you make a Tata Nano a
self-driving car can you have a low-cost
self-driving car by actually the
computer actually back and it's not like
we have a brilliant of GPUs inside your
network inside a car and so on okay
that's one example where you can think
about you can democratize
the ability of doing it by doing it more
that's one way of thinking about but
low-cost not the only thing but so what
that's one sort of natural way of
thinking about it yeah and I thought of
the goal here is sort of vision of this
sort of having more in network
computational capability is sort of a
natural way of dealing with a bunch of
these different distributed applications
and so again given that the cloud and
the HR both had to change the network
actually might be the way to sort of do
things so again this is not a sort of a
single systems or a machine learning or
a hardware problem it's really sort of a
cross-cutting problem where as I said
there's a very diverse team from
multiple universities but working
towards this vision looking at machine
learning for resilience building these
sort of trustworthy computation systems
from scratch sort of safe secure and
smart programming building cool new
special temporally aware applications
better in network coordination and
control mekin
as well as sort of new hardware
architectures and instead of maybe even
like some of the compact machine
learning algorithms that can run at the
edge and so on okay early days is really
less than six months since we launched
so this is sort of a long term effect
long long term effort that we're
actually launching right now so research
fellows are other people in this room
were applying for grad school we are
hiring aggressively cool that's it I'm
done